bonjour à tous ravis de vous revoir pour
animer cette dernière table ronde sur la
thématique comment reconquérir
l'électorat urbain et pour tenter de
répondre à cette question nous avons la
chance d'avoir des personnalités avec
des profils très variés nous commençons
par jean luc moudenc maire de toulouse
et président de toulouse métropole c'est
un peu au final irréductibles gaulois
qui arrive à garder son patient à droite
dans une zone de gauche alors qui de
mieux placé pour répondre à cette
question lui qui a été en mesure de
regagner toulouse nous avons ensuite
jean philipp etter chef de l'opposition
à la ville et à l'eurométropole de
strasbourg et conseiller départemental
jean philippe s'est présenté à la mairie
strasbourg lors des dernières élections
est confronté chaque jour à une
municipalité qui fait beaucoup parler
d'elle les écologistes communistes il
s'est notamment fermement opposée à une
subvention de 2,5 millions d'euros par
la ville de strasbourg pour la
construction d'une mosquée qui prône un
islam rigoriste lui qui mène son combat
politique dans la capitale européenne
pourra sans doute nous apporter une
analyse très pertinente
daniel fasquelle maire du touquet depuis
2008 il est également actuellement
conseiller régional des hôtes france il
était également député jusqu'en 2020 et
10 président de la commission des
affaires économiques
et puis président du comité régional de
tourisme est également professeur de
droit spécialisé en droit européen
ce qui va d'ailleurs lui permettre
d'avoir une analyse temps tant qu'élu
local qu en tant qu élu national mais il
est surtout le trésorier des
républicains ce qui fait de lui mesdames
messieurs notre nouveau meilleur ami
et pour finir avocat écrivain
chroniqueur je ne présente plus charles
concilie view de ses 33 ans ce brillant
intellectuel à la vie déjà bien remplie
connu notamment pour ses coups de gueule
charles consigny c'est un peu notre
révolutionnaire à nous il représente la
droite qui s'assume la classe dominante
sans honte toujours prête à se moquer
d'une gauche bien pensante et
politiquement correct et puis parmi ses
cibles préférées en vrac anne hidalgo
ian brossât et leur politique qu'il
qualifie de corée du nord aujourd'hui
avec nous loin des caméras loin des
micros hors du ring de boxe charles
consigny bienvenue bienvenue à vous tous
on merci à tous d'être présent
aujourd'hui pour ouvrir cette table
ronde je propose de laisser la parole à
jean luc on donne monsieur le maire vous
qui a été qu'ils avaient été en mesure
de regagner toulouse et de reconquérir
une métropole qui a été à gauche pour
cela je crois que vous avez vraiment
exécuter un plan de bataille assez
conséquent pour gagner quelques cei
pourriez vous nous donner pour
reconquérir l'électorat urbain vient
d'abord je veux remercier guillem de
m'avoir invité parce que c'est pas
souvent qu'on parle de ce sujet dans la
maison et donc j'ai dit oui bien sûr moi
je vais inscrire ma réponse dans les
propos de
notre député qui s'est exprimé tout à
l'heure et qui a fait l'éloge du terrain
effectivement on ne peut pas re
conquérir une grande ville uniquement
par twitter et les réseaux sociaux il
faut ça mais il faut d'abord être sur le
terrain c'est-à-dire près des gens près
des gens physiquement
alors il est temps de se remuer le
popotin puisque un tiers du mandat est
déjà consommé parce qu'en réalité il
faut s'y mettre tout de suite tous les
jours si on n'y pense pas tous les jours
si on a pas quelque chose à faire tous
les jours c'est mal barré pourquoi parce
que les villes sont des villes grandes
les populations bouge et donc c'est un
challenge difficile aujourd'hui sur les
onze villes qui font plus de deux cent
mille habitants en france la gauche en
détiennent neuf
nous une
quand on prend les 42 villes qui ont
plus de cent mille habitants la gauche
en a 23 et nous en avons 12 donc
effectivement le sujet il est plus
difficile
donc ce que disait alors être être sur
le terrain c'est une vérité nationale
quand on est en ville il faut en faire
dix fois plus diffuse alors ce que j'ai
fait - toulouse à partir de 2008 c'est
que je me suis mis dès 2008
j'ai créé une association
avec trois fonctions la communication
bien sur le terrain et donc j'ai
structuré des équipes de terrain par
secteur par quartier
des groupes de travail parce qu'il faut
avoir un projet
et puis tout le monde n'est pas je
dirais enclins à aller sur le terrain il
y en a qui préfèrent amener une
contribution intellectuelle et donc ces
trois choses avec une association ayant
statut de parti politique ce qui permet
de recueillir des dons et d'avoir les
moyens d'avancer
le terrain ça veut dire qu'on va à
toutes les inaugurations du maire pour
incarner l'alternative
on voit les gens on leur parle on leur
laisse une gare de visite on a toujours
sur soi un bulletin d'adhésion à
l'association qu'on a créé pour ce qui
nous encourage
le terrain
ensuite la thématique sur le projet
c'est là où il faut être sélectif parce
qu'effectivement quand vous attaquez à
une municipalité sortante c'est rare que
les gens soient mécontents de tous en
attendant ce qu on est opposant être un
peu contre tout bon donc il faut faire
un travail de sélection est rude études
d'opinion regarder quels sont les thèmes
ou le maire sortant n'est pas attaqué à
ce moment là on n'en parle pas et par
contre sélectionner les quelques thèmes
bien jamais énormément les quelques
thèmes ou par contre il est défaillant
il a il faut attaquer mais il faut aussi
réfléchir et proposer parce qu'une
opposition crédible c'est pas une
opposition qui se contente d'avoir des
postures ou des sûr dans ses
propositions qu'il faut donner aux gens
un moment qu'une proposition alternative
pour ça il n'y a pas de pas de secret il
faut travailler et donc il ya des
thématiques se dirait traditionnels que
nous devons tenir parce que l'erreur ça
serait d'abandonner nos thématiques
traditionnelles pour conquérir des
nouveaux électeurs
falloir tenir notre lectorat et
conquérir de nouveaux électorat des
nouvelles parts de marché donc il faut
être fort sur la sécurité qui est un
véritable problème en france mais plus
encore dans les grandes villes il faut
être fort sur les seniors le patrimoine
des thèmes peu traditionnelle et puis il
faut aller sur des thèmes on n'est pas
forcément attendu évidemment l'écologie
il faut compatissent notre vision de
l'écologie avec nos valeurs de liberté
et avec une écologie qui bien évidemment
ménages l'entreprise et la croissance il
faut aller également sur la thématique
sociale
abandonné le social à une municipalité
de gauche parce que des deux villes sauf
du mouvement de gauche ça s'appelle une
démission le démission mort donc là
aussi il faut faire travailler les
méninges pour avoir un projet social qui
soit celui de nos valeurs mais qui
répondent aux
préoccupations des gens et puis il faut
aller aussi sur des thématiques et des
publics qui souvent sont très
sociologiquement et politiquement
marqués et pas dans notre sens tous les
thématiques de l'innovation de la
recherche de l'enseignement supérieur
de l'ateq de l'intelligence artificielle
les start up
il faut pas que la modernité ce soit eux
nous aussi on incarne humour d une
modernité différentes donc voilà je
dirais un certain nombre de choses et
puis alors après quand on arrive à
l'élection il vous faire des alliances
tom regarder les grandes villes si vous
prenez la présidentielle de 2012 qui est
intéressante parce que c'est la dernière
présidentielle classique droite gauche
au second tour l'écart entre hollande et
sarkozy c'est 3% dans les grandes villes
c'est pas 3% c'est 10%
quand vous regardez les grandes villes
en 2022 vous voyez qu'au premier tour
les gauches fonds 41 ans et demi alors
qu'en france moyenne nationale on est à
30 6% quand vous regardez le score de
macron dans les grandes villes il est
grosso modo deux mille fois plus que la
moyenne nationale
et puis quand vous regardez le score du
rassemblement national
alors là il ya un gap d'immenses on se
montre tour il ya quelques mois il ya eu
17 % de différence entre maquereau et le
pen
en france dans les grandes villes 54% et
donc à partir de là il faut faire des
alliances vouloir aller au combat
uniquement avec elle est rude et ici
c'est sympa on défend drapeau ses
plaisirs mais gagne pas dans la plupart
des grandes villes je dirais pas la même
chose à nice je ne dirais pas la même
chose à tout le monde mais la majorité
des grandes villes et donc effectivement
il faut faire des alliances très très
large il faut prendre tout ce qu'il y a
entre la gauche et le rassemblement
national avec une forte dose de
société civile
et c'est comme ça que vous pouvez bâtir
une grande alliance après il faut faire
des alliances
sociologique là aussi ça serait une
erreur que d'être uniquement dans nos
quartiers de prédilection il faut aller
vers les quartiers populaires les
quartiers de la politique de la ville
vers les hlm parce que c'est un
électorat qui bouge beaucoup plus que
l'électorat des bobos vous pouvez aller
le voir 10 x ou fait mille choses pour
eux changeront pas leur vote par contre
dans le quartier populaire c'est pas la
même chose donc là aussi il ya parfois
des préjugés à revoir et après il faut
faire les alliances je dirais
intellectuelle entre familles de pensée
entre courants de pensée religieux
philosophiques il faut être attentif aux
communautés étrangères est d'origine
étrangère qui sont importantes dans les
grandes villes et discerner ce qu'ils
ont fait cet effort d'intégration et
d'assimilation qui est dans notre
discours et nos valeurs et il faut aller
à leur rencontre et il faut les mettre
en valeur et je vous assure ça amène
beaucoup voilà donc il y à toutes ces
alliances à faire et puis les alliances
faut les faire au premier tour il ya
rien de pire que les alliances au second
tour ça ne marche pas
on l'a vu dans plusieurs villes
les annonces du premier tour puisque
l'on met ensemble des gens différents ça
fait tous et pour mieux les gens tous au
premier tour plusieurs mois avant
l'élection plutôt que tous et à cinq
jours du tour décisif
ça permet d'expliquer 2 gérer etc
voilà voilà certainement de conseil que
je donnerais alors après évidemment il
ya des spécificités
aucune grande ville ne se ressemblent
mais il ya quand même dans les grandes
villes françaises un minimum de données
sociologiques qui sont identiques qui ne
sont pas en notre faveur et qui réclame
donc un effort spécifique et un effort
plus considérable qu'a lieu
[Applaudissements]
alors justement jean philippe vous qui
vous battez chaque jour entre
municipalités écolo-communistes
emblématique est ce que vous pourriez
faire un premier bilan de l'action de
ces nouvelles municipalités de gauche
qui ont pris d'assaut à ma droite alors
merci beaucoup irène merci à guilhem
d'avoir organisé ce débat et on voit
d'ailleurs avec le discours de jean-luc
à quel point nous nous portons un débat
intéressant et important parce que
effectivement les grandes villes ont un
rayonnement particulier sur nos
territoires et donc aussi sur notre pays
et c'est essentiel de pouvoir préparer
les chances de 2026 de la manière la
plus efficace possible je peux porter un
témoignage auprès de vous parce que je
suis lui à strasbourg et nous avons
aujourd'hui une municipalité verte et
communistes et je peux attester à quel
point
depuis deux ans il réalise un incroyable
travail de sape de tout ce qui se fait à
strasbourg et s'ils ont été élus pour
planter des arbres aujourd'hui ils ont
surtout réussi à planter strasbourg est
par exemple sur la thématique
fiscale ils n'ont pas augmenté de 2 ou 3
% les impôts locaux les ont augmenté de
400% on a quand même été capable
d'expliquer que les rats qui
malheureusement pullulent dans nos
quartiers sont pas des nuisibles mais
des animaux
nerfs qu'il faut avec lesquels il faut
apprendre à vivre je peux vous dire que
pour ces personnes le quartier c'est
très difficile à vivre idem pour les
punaises de lit nous avons aussi une
municipalité qui donne 2 5 millions
d'euros de subventions non pas une
association environnementale
mais à une mosquée qui est retenu parmi
les gros riches qui se situe à la droite
du conservateur erdogan en turquie c'est
à dire que vraiment c'est un islam
extrêmement rigoriste et ce sont les
mêmes qui nous explique qu'il faut
combattre
l'homophobie ou encore agir en faveur
des droits des femmes c'est dire à quel
point il ya un discrédit lien double
discours que nous devons absolument
combattre dans les grandes villes que ce
soit à strasbourg mais aussi à bordeaux
à lyon et enfin aussi par exemple à
marseille encore d'autres villes et je
veux vous dire le fond de ma pensée ces
écologistes ne défendent pas l'écologie
l'écologie n'est pas un but l'écologie
est un prétexte comme d'ailleurs la
lutte des classes était un prétexte dans
les années 30 pour l'ensemble des
communistes le prétexte c'est de briser
les liens sociaux actuels le prétexte de
briser nos repères nos traditions il
s'attaque par exemple à noël non
seulement à bordeaux mais aussi à
strasbourg qui est la capitale de noël
donc vous imaginez c'est comme si jean
luc se mettaient à combattre le
cassoulet à toulouse donc c'est vraiment
on est vraiment on est vraiment à contre
emploi et s'étire à quel point mes chers
amis on a une responsabilité et jean-luc
nous donne des clés pour gagner les
villes il faut qu'on puisse gagner les
grandes villes françaises en 2026 non
seulement pour notre mouvement mais
aussi pour l'ensemble du territoire
parce que c'est vraiment défendre
l'intérêt général de faire en sorte que
ces verres etc communiste n'est plus les
manettes dans ses grandes lignes
et du coup aujourd'hui comment vous
comptez séduire l'électorat urbain et
reconquérir la ville en 2026 alors
j'aimerais partager une réflexion avec
vous c'est qu'à mon sens l'électorat des
grandes villes c'est un électorat un
petit peu particulier il faut le prendre
en compte
jean-luc me faisait cette confidence
hier en me disant qu'il faisait partie
des 30 % de toulousain né à toulouse
c'est dire à quel point vous avez pas d
électeurs qui sont forcément enracinée
dans les grandes villes ça fait deux ans
qui viennent à strasbourg et peut-être
dans trois ans ils sont partis et donc
vous avez des électeurs qui sont à mon
sens surtout le mondialisée ils se
préoccupent de ce qui se passe au coin
de la rue un petit peu mais aussi de ce
qui se passe aux quatre coins du monde
et lors de l'élection me parle beaucoup
de la forêt qui brûle en australie du
pic de température en sibérie de du
manque d'eau dans certaines parties du
monde et donc effectivement ce sont des
problématiques dont on me parle et ne
pensez pas que c'est seulement les bobos
de gauche qui en parle vous avez de plus
en plus une droite bourgeoise qui est
d'ailleurs vraiment conservatrice qui
sont chefs d'entreprise qui ont peut
être même une belle voiture dans le
garage mais qui au moment de voter sont
très sensibles à ces questions
environnementales et qui demande à la
droite de pouvoir les porter mais
aujourd'hui un constat d'échec
c'est que quand vous allez aux urnes
citez moi vraiment une des centaines et
des milliers de personnes qui vont voter
pour la droite parce qu'il pense qu'on
est les meilleurs sur l'environnement je
suis pas sûr que ce soit le cas je suis
pas sûr que aujourd'hui on rayonne comme
un parti qui prend en compte vraiment
l'environnement et pourtant ce constat
d'échec est assez cruel parce que qui a
été le premier grand ministre de
l'environnement c'est michel barnier qui
a été le premier à dire que la maison
brûle c'est jacques chirac qui ont été
les premiers albums à m'ôter à monter le
grenelle de l'environnement cdc
évidemment la droite et donc nous avons
un merveilleux bilan mais par contre
nous avons manifestement un problème de
lisibilité
et nous prenons aujourd'hui l'écologie
comme un plus par rapport à notre projet
traditionnel mais pas au coeur de notre
projet alors à mon sens il ya deux
petites mais la première c'est le local
on a la chance d'avoir des maires comme
jean-luc ou encore d'autres maires de
communes de collectivités chéri rennes
comme le grand s ou encore celle des
départements je suis membre de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace on met
en oeuvre des formidables politique
environnementale il faut qu'on en parle
davantage et qu'on se coordonnent
peut-être avec jean-luc
l'ensemble de ces communes mais aussi
des masques et les écolos nous avons des
oppositions dans les grandes villes nous
devons rédiger un livre noir des villes
vertes pour qu'on puisse montrer à quel
point ils ne font pas de l'écologie ils
font de l'idéologie il faut de la
déconstruction notre société il parle
beaucoup plus de barbecue de virilité ou
d'hommes qui potentiellement peuvent
tomber en simple que d'écologie de
réponse concrets
il faut qu'on puisse mettre ainsi en
avant et enfin mais c'est la question
des idées parce que c'est celle qui fait
bouger le monde il faut qu'on puisse
travailler ensemble dans les trois ou
quatre années sur un corpus d'idées de
pensée soit une écologie de droite que
j'appellerais une écologie bleus une
écologie bleus qui pensent pas seulement
l'écologie comme l'appendice après la
sécurité l'identité nos traditions
l'immigration mais qu'ils soient
vraiment au coeur d'un projet où
justement on arrive à intégrer cette
vision de l'entreprise cette vision
notre société cette vision de deux
rapports entre l'homme et la femme et
avec l'environnement une écologie bleus
qui a une vraie différence avec les
écolos c'est con mais l'homme au coeur
de notre projet on considère pas que
l'homme est responsable de tout ce qui
est coupable et tout ce qui se passe mal
dans notre société mais au contraire que
l'homme peut être la part de solutions
et on le voit dans le développement des
startups qui trouve des solutions on le
voit dans nos entreprises qui font des
super bénéfices qui doit se transformer
en super investissements dans l'écologie
et bien cette écologie bleus j'aimerais
vraiment qu'on arrive à la porter
ensemble pour être crédibles ces
thématiques et montrer que l'écologie
elle peut faire et non pas seulement
comme les vers le fond défaire je
remercie
alors c'est vrai qu'on a aussi un autre
phénomène monsieur le maire vous allez
pouvoir nous en parler parce que c'est
vrai que de plus en plus les urbains ont
tendance à quitter les grandes villes
pour des villes un peu plus agréable un
peu moins peuplé alors vous qui est qui
est m mr du tout les pardons comment
comment gérez vous votre vie est d'abord
bonjour à tous et puis félicitations aux
jeunes d'avoir pu organiser ce beau
rassemblement donc bravo à stéphane à la
fédération ici aux jeunes républicains
de maine-et-loire et puis à guilhem à
toute son équipe et puis c'est vrai que
je suis votre meilleur nouvel avis et ça
voilà donc on a ouvert un peu les
cordons de la bourse mais je voulais
vous féliciter parce que vous avez fait
un beau rassemblement national avec des
moyens très très limité et jouets saluer
annie genevard ici parce que et d une
formidable président de notre mouvement
c'est elle aussi qui a souhaité que ce
rassemblement se fasse qui vous a
soutenu dans ce projet dans cette idée
donc merci et bravo à toi n'y
c'est bien la preuve qu'on doit faire
beaucoup de choses avec peu de moyens et
bravo et c'est peut-être aussi une
valeur une vertu de droite
ce que je constate c'est qu'en fait
pendant des années des années on avait
des partis politiques qui s'adressait à
tous les français
aujourd'hui on a eu des partis
politiques qui s'adresse à une partie
des français seulement vous avez macro
qui s'adresse à la france qui va bien
vous avez marine le pen qui s'adresse à
la france qui va mal ou qui pensent
qu'elle va mal et puis vous avez
mélenchon qui s'adresse à la france des
banlieues et ça donne une france qui est
extrêmement fracturé et un paysage
politique qui devient illisible et nous
nous avons vocation en tout cas j'en
suis absolument persuadé à parler à tous
les français mais pour cela il faut
évidemment que l'on construise un
discours qui soit audible audi pour la
france rurale audi pour la france
urbaine audi pour les jeunes pour les
milieux économiques parce que petit à
petit on s'est coupé on s'est coupé des
jeunes qui sont très peu a voté pour
nous et c'est là où c'est important
d'avoir un mouvement de jeunes qui comme
le vote va de l'avant et saura parler
renouer le lien avec les jeunes on ne
parle plus aux milieux économiques
les milieux économiques
j'étais encore aux rencontres
entreprises de france organisé par le
medef les milieux économiques
eh bien ils se tournent plus volontiers
vers vers macro et l'offre macron que
vers nous alors qu un moment on avait un
lien fort avec les milieux économiques
quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs y compris
d'ailleurs les artisans et les
commerçants c'est tout à fait c'est tout
à fait dommage et puis même la france
populaire la france populaire à laquelle
on s'adresse plus dans petit à petit on
disparaît du paysage politique parce
qu'on appelle fléchois s'adresser à une
c'est un segment particulier d'opinion
publique mais aussi parce qu'on sait
plus parler à l'ensemble des français et
je crois que justement pour nous
distinguer des autres partis politiques
et autres formations politiques il faut
qu'on retrouve et je salue les candidats
qui sont ici ou non eric
aurélien ya serge qui étaient là mais ce
sera leur responsabilité demain de faire
en sorte que notre mouvement s'adresse à
nouveau à l'ensemble des français ça me
semble extrêmement important à qui faut
redonner espoir parce qu'aujourd'hui les
français se détournent aussi de la
politique parce qu'ils ont perdu espoir
en où ils ont perdu parfois espoir dans
leur propre pays et on subit un déclin
des classements qui est incroyable je le
regardais dans le figaro économie de ce
week-end y avait des chiffres qui
étaient très intéressants une
comparaison avec la suisse dans les
années 70 le
niveau de vie des français éthique et
valence celui des suisses aujourd'hui
les suisses ont un niveau de vie qui est
deux fois supérieur à celui des français
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé durant
toutes ces années donc il faut
absolument reconstruire un projet qui
soit un projet social économique
crédible et qui parle à l'ensemble des
français et qui redonne l'espoir à
chaque français quel qu'il soit qu'il
vit dans le milieu rural ou dans le
milieu urbain qu'ils soient jeunes ou
moins jeunes saab semble extrêmement
important il faut aussi que l'on porte à
nouveau une vraie politique
d'aménagement du territoire on doit pas
accepter cette fragmentation entre une
france urbaine qui irait bien ou qui
restait propre volet matic par rapport à
une france rurale qui aurait d'autres
projets d'autres problématiques la
grandeur du gaullisme moi je viens d'une
famille gaulliste c'est justement de
savoir porter une vraie politique
d'aménagement du territoire qui fasse en
sorte que le pays ne soit plus
fracturées comme il est aujourd'hui et
là je crois qu'on a un vrai discours a
porté sur la place de l'état on a eu
tort pendant trop longtemps de parler de
l'état uniquement en nombre de
fonctionnaires à réduire bien sûr qu'il
faut réduire le nombre de fonctionnaires
je les fais dans ma commune 7 600 à 500
ont fait plus de choses et la ville va
mieux mais on peut pas parler d'état
quand nombre de fonctionnaires l'état
doit s'y retrouver sa place son rôle et
ça me semble extrêmement important je
cite souvent l'exemple de la du
téléphone de l'électricité de gaulle a
fait en sorte que les français le
téléphone filaire et électricité
l'ensemble des français aux mêmes
conditions pour la téléphonie mobile et
c'était une erreur de la droite on a
fait confiance aux opérateurs privés ce
qui fait que dans les villes les
consommateurs uniquement en qualité
consommateurs ont eu la téléphonie
mobile la 4g à 5 g pour avoir la même
chose chez nous il faut que l'on paye en
tant que consommateurs mais également en
tant que contribuable puisque les
communautés de communes les communes les
départements les régions dû mettre de
l'argent ce n'est pas normal on doit pas
l'accepter et on doit retrouver un
discours de droite sur la place de
l'état pour faire en sorte qu'ils aient
pas plusieurs france mais une seule
france et puis je dirais qu ensuite on
ne met pas assez en avant ce qu'on est
capable de faire dans nos communes les
maires qui sont ici non ils sont
nombreux on a des politiques qui sont
tout à fait exemplaire et qui correspond
normalement à ce qu attend les français
en terme de sécurité moi j'ai créé une
police municipale dans ma commune et
j'ai renforcé la sécurité en termes de
propreté va regarder l'état de paris
regarde les regarder l'état des villes
qui sont gérées par la gauche c'est une
véritable catastrophe
ces villes ne sont pas sûres elles sont
sales or ce qu'on attend d'abord et
avant tout des villes qu'elle soit
propre salle et soit bien géré aussi
regarder l'explosion aujourd'hui la taxe
foncière parce qu'ils sont incapables de
gérer leur budget les taxes et la
fiscalité locale exposé aujourd'hui et
c'est le fait des villes de gauche et
puis en matière d'environnement et je
sais que jean luc le fait dans sa
commune je le fais dans ma commune on a
aussi des politiques qui sont tout à
fait exemplaire mais je suis en zéro
phyto déjà depuis plusieurs années j'ai
en face nous aurons palais des congrès
retirer l'équivalent un terrain de
football de macadam et les gens sont
très contents donc on a des politiques
environnementales qui sont tout à fait
exemplaire lancé pâle suffisamment le
mettre en avant ce qui fait qu'à la fin
les gens vote écolo parce qu'ils pensent
que ce sont eux qui seront mieux faire
une place aux déplacements doux au à
l'environnement dans nos vies alors que
c'est pas vrai alors qu'on sait le faire
donc je pense qu'il ya aussi une
question de pédagogie à faire quant à la
capacité des élus de droite à bien gérer
nos villes demain et à renouer le lien
avec les tissus urbains voilà moi je
suis plein d'espoir pour la suite quand
je vois aujourd'hui quand je sais ce
qu'on est capable de faire dans nos
communes merci de m'avoir écouté
alors charles justement vous qu'il y
avait un franc parler vous êtes connu
pour ça vous êtes un peu notre grande
gueule préféré à tous
vous avez dit récemment que il faudrait
un peu des regards 10 et la droite et
puis comment s'adresser un peu plus à la
jeunesse puisque il ya beaucoup de
jeunes dans des milieux urbains
comment faire pour les garder ringardisé
par mon la droite et puis un peu plus
parler à la jeune assis et goûter merci
beaucoup de votre invitation je suis
très content d'être là jeu j'essaie de
rassembler mes neurones depuis tout à
l'heure après la soirée que nous avons
eue hier avec
la grande équipe de rugby que
constituent les jeunes républicains
qui nous qui nous qui ont fait plus j'ai
plus l'absence dans une espèce de mêlée
qui n'en finissait pas que sur une piste
de danse je constate que nadine morano
qui étaient avec nous hier n'est pas
présente ce matin
et à chaque jour suffit sa peine est
elle a valeureusement livrer le combat
hier soir dans sept dans cette même
salle
je voudrais dire aussi
moi je me fais un peu le poil à gratter
bien sûr mais on constate ici et je le
dis en présence de la presse j'espère
qu'il en reste un peu que ce parti des
magnifiques en réalité contrairement à
ce qu'ils disent on est ici extrêmement
nombreux les gens sont sont extrêmement
motivés notamment les jeunes je ne sais
pas s'il ya autant de jeunes sincèrement
motivé dans ce parti au nom vieillot qui
renaissance ou chez horizon entre deux
barres bleues
sordide je ne sais pas si derrière la
barbe de plus en plus crépusculaire
d'edouard philippe
je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait aucun jeune
motivé et je sais plus qui me disait un
journalisme posé la question il me
disait mais alors est-ce que ça n'est
pas le moment soit de rejoindre
puisqu'on fait l'objet de cette double
offensive l'offensive à la droite à
notre droite
et l'offensive du au centre droit est-ce
que ça n'est pas le moment finalement de
se scinder d'en rejoindre l'un et
l'autre mais je dis vous connaissez pas
le mot de foch que tout le monde connaît
ici je pense ma gauche est enfoncée ma
droite recule mon centre cède le moment
est favorable
j'attaque eh ben je pense que pour vous
pour nous pour les républicains le
moment est favorable pour attaquer
quand on voit les adversaires qu'on a
j'ai parlé d' edouard philippe bruno le
maire qui promettait de faire
s'effondrer l'économie russe grâce à
leurs mesures si pertinente finalement
on apprend que l'économie russe s'est
jamais aussi bien portée et que c'est
nous qui allons nous retrouver sans
chauffage sans électricité sans je sens
un show de cet hiver est une belle
performance de bruno le maire quand
j'entends les déclarations de macron qui
peut pas s'empêcher de parler toujours
avec des dorures en font en fond de
décor il a toujours pas retenu sondés
gilet jaune et donc il s'exprime avec un
air plein d'emphase en nous expliquant
que c'est la fin de l'abondance et que
donc voilà on allait dire oui mais
l'abondance il ya plein de gens qui la
connaissent pas l'abondance ça n'est pas
que la france qui va bien la france qui
votent macron donc moi je pense que le
moment il est favorable pour attaquer et
rappelez moi votre question puisque
j'essaie de rassembler mais le rhône
mais je vais y arriver dans un instant
c'est la droite
est en fait elle est par un garde elle
est là
elle le prouve
non
moi je pense qu'il y a une méthode une
méthode simple d'abord c'est de livrer
bataille je pense qu'on
on a pu avoir tendance ces dernières
années subissant des assauts divers et
variés les assauts furieux de d'eric
zemmour les assauts plus en douceur de
marine le pen les débauchages les
trahisons aussi il faut bien le dire de
certains qui ont quitté le navire on a
pu avoir tendance finalement à ne plus
livrer bataille à ne plus vouloir
affirmer nos idées et je pense que
l'essentiel c'est de mener cette
bataille je pense aussi que ça ça a été
un petit mais on doit assumer nous aussi
d'avoir un discours sur l'écologie qui
devient aujourd'hui un sujet absolument
majeur et on doit assumer aussi le fait
de le faire de manière offensive moi je
pense qu'il ya un fascisme vert qui est
en train de se développer
notamment chez la jeune génération jeu
j'observe que il y en a ici il faudra
pas trop les poussées pour bientôt tout
interdire à titre personnel je n'ai rien
contre les jets privés j'adore le
l'aviation je pense qu'il ne faut pas
casser des outils de pointe de la france
l'aviation c'est un domaine dans lequel
la france est en pointe pour les beaux
yeux de quelques quelques militants qui
en plus reconnaissent eux mêmes que ce
sont là des symboles et donc je pense
qu'on doit on doit assumer ce qu'on ait
assumé ce conte ce qu'on veut défendre
pour me faire toujours aussi un peu poil
à gratter je pense qu'on doit se mettre
en phase avec notre époque je crois que
par exemple sur les sujets les questions
de la famille la manif pour tous le
mariage pour tous moi je pense à titre
personnel que la droite a beaucoup perdu
en s'acoquinant avec ces mouvements je
sais que je me ferais pas que des amis
dans cette salle
mais je ne suis pas sûr que la proximité
de certains avec lui devine de la
rochère et avec quelques quelques
personnes qui battaient le pavé pour
empêcher un truc aussi simple que de
permettre à deux personnes de même sexe
d'avoir les mêmes droits que les autres
je ne suis pas sûr que que suivent ces
gens là étaient une bonne une bonne
option
donc je crois qu'il faut voilà faire un
effort pour être en phase avec notre
époque et puis
je j'essaye toujours de rassembler mes
neurones mais mais mais c'est en train
de se produire sous vos yeux et bay je
pense je pense aussi que il ne faut pas
avoir pour qu est ce qui nous distingue
au fond des macros nist qu'est ce qui
fait qu'on ne peut pas se fondre dans la
droite macro nien au delà de moi ce que
je crois être une certaine proximité
avec le monde de l'argent qui n'est pas
notre droite je pense que la droite
gaulliste ça n'est pas une droite qui
est soumise aux grandes puissances de
l'argent et je pense que macro s'est
comporté en réalité depuis cinq ans
comme le mandataire de quelques grands
intérêts financiers ça c'est mon avis
personnel je pense que la droite qui est
ici représentée elle est plus du côté de
l'intérêt général
je pense que ce qui nous distingue c'est
tout simplement le courage réformateur
c'est ce que valérie pécresse a essayé
et j'ai été très fier de la soutenir
jusqu'au bout de sa campagne
présidentielle parce que je trouve
qu'elle a fait preuve d'une ténacité
d'un courage incroyable
compte tenu de ce qu'elle avait
compte tenu de ce qu'elle avait contre
elle
de même que j'ai été très fier de porter
les couleurs des républicains aux
législatives
dans une circonscription complètement
boboïsée des yvelines où notre où notre
corpus idéologique n'était plus en phase
malheureusement avec avec ces cyclistes
finalement que sous les sont devenus les
français mais ils ont raison pour pour
une part moi j'aime à titre personnel
les 4 4 mais mais mais chacun chacun
fait comme il l'entend je sais que ce
sera bientôt interdit je vous dis
d'ailleurs profiter de tout ça avant que
ce soit interdit je dire achetez vous un
4 4 construisez une piscine je n'ai pas
profitez-en avant que vous n'ayez plus
le droit
avant qu'on soit tous
dans des dents des kolkhozes et dans des
sacs cause avant qu'on ait des tickets
de rationnement c'est déjà le cas je
dire qu'est ce que le chèque alimentaire
si ce n'est en fait une espèce de
nouveaux tickets de rationnement avant
qu'on ait un impasse écologique qu'on
aura droit de prendre x minutes le matin
sa douche sinon on aura sandrine
rousseau qui descendra en rappel
sur le balcon notre appartement mais
bien sûr c'est ça le
c'est ça l'avenir
et donc je vais donc je pense qu'on doit
assumer de défendre de défendre nos
idées tout simplement faire un travail
programmatique je pense que c'est
important se départir de quelques
vieilles lunes et assumer d'être
tranchant sur la réforme moi je pense
qu'il ya en france et là je pense qu'on
est tous d'accord pour le dire un
problème sur le travail il ya quelqu'un
qui n'est pas présent ici mais que
certains aient l'esprit qui dénoncent
depuis longtemps l'assistanat et je
pense que et je pense qu'il a raison
quand j'ai voulu déposer mon dossier de
candidature à la préfecture du
département où j'étais candidat j'ai
vérifié jusqu'à quelle heure je pouvais
le faire parce que je suis avocat je
connais certaines administrations et je
me méfie des horaires maintenant de plus
en plus dans l'administration et
je j'ai bien fait de vérifier puisque la
préfecture en question je ne citerai pas
fermé à 15 heures à partir de 15h vous
ne pouviez plus vous n'aviez plus axé
vers moi si je ferme mon cabinet à 15h
pardon mais je je je n'ai plus de quoi
vivre donc ça il ya un vrai sujet là
dessus sur le sur le travail et donc je
pense que plus on proposera des réformes
tranchante plus en proposera une ligne
tranchante plus on proposera par exemple
de remettre au boulot les fonctionnaires
de la mairie de paris puisqu'il est
question de l'électorat urbain qui ne
veulent même pas faire leurs 35 heures
vous avez beaucoup de piscines
municipales sont restées fermées à paris
cet été parce que les fonctionnaires
faisait grève parce qu'on voulait les
passés aux 35 heures parce qu'ils
étaient en dessous plus on sera radicaux
là dessus plus on sera clairement à
droite et plus à mon avis on arrivera à
convaincre les français
alors justement monsieur le maire du
touquet monsieur le trésorier j'aimerais
qu'on change de casquette et que je
m'adresse à vous en tant qu ancien élu
national pensez vous justement que
l'électorat urbain à d'autres
préoccupations il ya eu d'amour
l'écologie mais qu'est ce qu'on devrait
changer et est un peu s'adapter pour
créer un nouveau corpus idéologique pour
pour penser pour la droite de demain
pour la droite urbaine
alors par rapport à ce qui vient d'être
dit je pense qu'effectivement il faut
quand même qu'on soit attentif à
certaines préoccupations l'électorat
urbain alors ya la propreté et la
sécurité mis à l'environnement et la
question des déplacements doux on peut
détester anne hidalgo et quand on fait
beaucoup de vélo dans paris et ce qui
est ce qui est mon cas on apprécie aussi
les pistes cyclables donc il faut pas
abandonner ce genre de sujet à la gauche
les écologistes il faut absolument se
les réapproprier donc je pense qu'en
terme de 2 place de la nature dans nos
villes de déplacement doux de
convivialité aussi moi j'ai créé une
malterie pays zain heures j'ai créé une
école parental pour enfants autistes
la droite a toujours défendu la cause du
handicap il faut qu'on soit beaucoup
plus allants est fier de ce que l'on
fait dans ces domaines parce que si on
leur abandonne ces questions à la fin
les électeurs voteront pour eux plus tôt
pour nous uniquement pour ces raisons là
donc si on sait se réapproprier ces
raisons là on saura pas ce qu'on sait
qu'on est crédible sur les questions
sécurité de bonne gestion de propreté on
pourra reconquérir les grandes villes
parce que jean-luc l'a dit et je le
félicite parce que hélas il a su garder
toulouse mais on a quand même perdu
marseille on a perdu bordeaux on a pâli
l'on n'a pas pu reconquérir paris enfin
faut quand même savoir que dans les
grandes villes de notre pays on est
aujourd'hui absent strasbourg voilà
alors bien évidemment il faut
y penser dès maintenant et comme le
disait jean luc 1 il faut pas vous
mettre si vous êtes si vous êtes
intéressés par les prochaines élections
municipales faut pas vous y mettre six
mois avant c'est maintenant que ça
commence d'ailleurs je pense qu'il faut
aussi qu'on fasse une vraie place aux
jeunes dans nos communes et lors des
prochaines élections municipales qu'on
leur fasse confiance en pierre henri
dumont et balla ici des tories député du
pas de calais moi je me suis battu à
l'époque président la fédération elle
avait 26 ans pour donner l'investiture à
marck en calaisis il y avait quelqu'un
qui était qui voulaient toyas pour la
quatrième fois qu'ils avaient échoué à
chaque fois je sais que ça a été très
compliqué j'ai imposé pierre henri
dumont j'appose et pierre emmanuel
gibson qui étaient des jeunes du pas de
calais à béthune est bien pire et manu
agissions est aujourd'hui le premier
adjoint pierre henry a gagné la ville de
marcq il a gagné le canton aujourd'hui
les députés donc il faut que notre parti
sache aussi faire une vraie place aux
jeunes s'étaient d'hier vous n'êtes pas
là simplement pour distribuer des tracts
et coller des affiches saturne est la
démonstration est la preuve mais il faut
absolument que vous et puis il faut
faire une meilleure place aux femmes
aussi dans notre partie ou non ne vous
fait pas la démonstration ce matin à
cette tribune mais je trouve que voilà
et on en parlait haqqani ce matin mois
dans le pas-de-calais j'avais sur neuf
candidates et candidats républicains
j'avais huit femmes et un homme mais au
niveau national eric on n'a pas su
encore cette fois-ci obtenir la parité
pour les prochaines pour les dernières
élections législatives ce n'est pas
normal donc des règles disait le parti
sait aussi faire les frais place aux
jeunes et c'est faire une vraie place
aux femmes voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire ce matin également
alors ensuite il faut aussi de renouer
avec les milieux économiques
et puis puisque tu as fait allusion au
fait que j'enseignais droit harper à
l'université moi je pense qu'il faut pas
il faut vraiment que sur la question de
l'europe
françois-xavier belle amy est ici michel
barnier était présent hier on est
complètement inédit sur la question de
l'europe est là aussi bien emmanuel
macron avec son discours sur la sorbonne
a su capter cet électorat urbain qui est
plutôt favorable aux questions
européennes puisqu'on si on était
favorable à l'europe en voter macron et
puis marine le pen évidemment sur été
contre l'europe il fallait voter pour
marine le pen nous on a été
difficilement audible sur ce sujet
malgré tous les efforts de
françois-xavier bellamy et de nos amis
lors des deux élections européennes je
pense que sur ce sujet si on veut
renouer également avec cet électorat
urbain qui est plus ouvert aux questions
européennes ou à la mondialisation il
faut qu'on construise également un
discours qui soit plus plus crédible
plus allants sur les questions
européennes et c'est là où on compte
vraiment sur françois xavier est sûre
sur nos amis et puis il faut renouer je
le disais plus tôt avec eux aussi les
milieux économiques elle qui soit avec
les commerçants les artisans qu'on a
perdu et moi je me souviens il ya vingt
ans les les commerçants les artisans ils
voter à droite aujourd'hui ils votent
pas ou ils votent rassemblement national
malheureusement on les a perdus pour une
grande partie d'entre eux et puis les
dirigeants d'entreprises moyennes et
puis surtout les dirigeants
d'entreprises importantes les cadres des
grandes entreprises aujourd'hui est bien
quand ils pensent économies ils se
tournent plutôt vers emmanuel macron que
vers nous donc on a à construire un
discours à nouveau crédible et audible
en allant vers les milieux économiques
en allant vers les cadres en allant vers
ceux qui croient dans l'europe moi je
suis pro européen de gaulle l'été on est
un parti politique a toujours été et qui
a toujours défendu l'idée européenne et
qui a toujours voulu concilier justement
la préservation de l'identité française
et l'identité européennes la france et
peut-être forte demain en europe et dans
le monde grâce aussi à l'europe et à
travers l'europe dont je crois qu'il
faut qu'on soit aussi fiers et qu'on ait
un discours qui soit crédible et audible
sur ce sur ce sujet voilà ce que je
voulais ajouter en complément de tout ce
qu'on a dit ce matin dans tous les cas
bravo aux jeunes et puis faisons
vraiment une place aux jeunes et aux
femmes dans notre parti